hold on i need a minute  the ocean is particularly captivating  today  all right what's on the docket  nudibranchs  ah yes of course nudibranchs i love  these  nudibranchs are small  about the size of my fingertip  these are particularly amazing animals  and you can find them all over the world  if you look hard enough  on top these things that look like ears  are chemosensory organs  they help them see because nudibranchs  are pretty much blind they can only  sense light and dark their bright colors  aren't for one another obviously they're  to alert predators that they're  poisonous  but generally speaking  they're just adorable let's look at some  roll the tape  nudibranchs are hermaphroditic but  cannot mate alone so when these guys  aren't looking for food they're looking  for sex  not too bad a life  nudibrance sex crazed poisonous sea  slugs  can we put that on a t-shirt  perfect